are you thinking also when you say open
source at the hardware level is this
going to the design architecture
instruction set level or is it going to
literally the the you know the
manufacturer of the of the actual
hardware of the actual chips whether
that's a six specialized a particular
domain or the general yeah so let's talk
about that a little bit so when you get
down to the bottom layer of software the
way software talks to hardware is in a
vocabulary and what we call that
vocabulary we call that the words of
that vocabulary called instructions in
the technical term for the vocabulary is
instruction set so those instructions
are like we talked about earlier that
can be instructions like add subtract
and multiply divide there's instructions
to put data into memory which is called
a store instruction and to get data back
which is called what load instructions
and those simple instructions go back to
the very dawn of computing and you know
in in 1950 the commercial commercial
computer had these instructions so
that's the instruction set that we're
talking about so up until I'd say 10
years ago these instruction sets are all
proprietary so a very popular one is
olden by Intel the one that's in the
cloud and in all the pcs in the world
Intel owns that instruction set it's
referred to as the x86 there have been a
sequence of ones that the first number
was called 8086 and since then there's
been a lot of numbers but they all end
in 86 so there's been that kind of
family of instruction sets and that's
proprietary and that's proprietary the
other one that's very popular is from
arm that kind of powers all the all the
cell phones in the world all the iPads
in the world and a lot of things that
are so-called Internet of Things devices
arm and that one is also proprietary arm
will license it to people for a fee but
they own that so the new idea that got
started at Berkeley kind of
unintentionally ten years ago is
in early in my career we pioneered a way
to do these vocabularies instruction
sets that was very controversial at the
time at the time in the 1980s
conventional wisdom was these
vocabularies instruction set should have
you know powerful instructions so
polysyllabic kind of words you can think
of that and and so that instead of just
add subtract and multiply they would
have polynomial divided or sort a list
and the hope was of those powerful
vocabularies that make it easier for
software so we thought that didn't make
sense for microprocessors service people
at Berkeley and Stanford and IBM who
argued the opposite and we what we
called that was a reduced instruction
set computer in the abbreviation was our
ISC and typical for computer people we
use the abbreviations start pronouncing
it so risk was so we said for
microprocessors which with Gordon's
Moore is changing really fast we think
it's better to have a pretty simple set
of instructions reduce set of
instructions that that would be a better
way to build microprocessors since
they're going to be changing so fast due
to Moore's law and then we'll just use
standard software to cover the use
generate more of those simple
instructions and one of the pieces of
software that it's in a software stack
going between these layers of
abstractions is called a compiler and it
basically translates it's a translator
between levels we said the translator
will handle it
so the technical question was well since
there are these reduced instructions you
have to execute more of them yeah that's
right but maybe they execute them faster
yeah that's right there's simpler so
they could go faster but you have to do
more of them so what's what's that
trade-off looked like and it ended up
that we ended up executing maybe 50
percent more instructions maybe 1/3 more
instructions but they ran four times
faster so so this risk controversial
risk ideas proved to be maybe factors of
three or four better I love that this
idea was controversial and
most kind of like rebellious so that's
in the context of what was more
conventional is the complex
instructional set competing so how'd you
pronounce that Sisk Sisk risk vs. Sisk
and and believe it or not this sounds
very very you know who cares about this
right it was it was violently debated at
several conferences it's like what's the
brightman ago is is and people thought
risk was you know was de-evolution we're
gonna make software worse by making the
instructions simpler and they're fierce
debates at several conferences in the
1980s and then later in the eighties
that kind of settled to these benefits
it's not completely intuitive to me why
risk has for the most part one yes so
why did that happen yeah yeah and maybe
I can sort of say a bunch of dumb things
that could lay the land for further
commentary so to me and this is a this
is kind of interesting thing if you look
at c++ versus see with modern compilers
you really could write faster code with
c++ so relying on the compiler to reduce
your complicated code into something
simple and fast so to me comparing risk
maybe this is a dumb question but why is
it that focusing the definition the
design of the instruction set on very
few simple instructions in the long run
provide faster execution versus coming
up with like he said a ton of
complicated instructions then over time
you know years maybe decades you come up
with compilers that can reduce those
into simple instructions for you yeah
some let's try and split that into two
pieces so if the compiler can do that
for you if the pilot can take you know a
complicated program and produce simpler
instructions then the programmer doesn't
care right programmer yeah yeah I don't
care just how how fast is the computer
I'm using how much does it cost and so
what we what
and kind of in the software industry is
right around before the 1980s critical
pieces of software were still written
not in languages like C or C++ they were
written in what's called assembly
language where there's this kind of
humans writing exactly at the
instructions at the level then that a
computer can understand so they were
writing add subtract multiply you know
instructions it's very tedious but the
belief was to write this lowest level of
software that the people use which are
called operating systems they had to be
written in assembly language because
these high-level languages were just too
inefficient they were too slow or the
the programs would be too big so that
changed with a famous operating system
called UNIX which is kind of the the
grandfather of all the operating systems
today so the UNIX demonstrated that you
could write something as complicated as
an operating system in a language like C
so once that was true then that meant we
could hide the instruction set from the
programmer and so that meant then it
didn't really matter the programmer
didn't have to write lots of these
simple instructions so that was up to
the compiler so that was part of our
arguments for risk is if you were still
writing assembly languages maybe a
better case for sis constructions but if
the compiler can do that it's going to
be you know that's done once the
computer translates at once and then
every time you run the program it runs
that this this potentially simpler
instructions and so that that was the
debate right is because and people would
acknowledge that these simpler
instructions could lead to a faster
computer you can think of mono syllabic
instructions you could say them you know
if you think of reading you probably
read them faster or say them faster than
long instructions the same thing that
analogy works pretty well for hardware
and as long as you didn't have to read a
lot more of those instructions you could
win so that's that's kind of that's the
basic idea for risk but it's interesting
that the in that discussion of UNIX does
see that there's only one step
of levels of abstraction from the code
that's really the closest to the machine
to the code that's written by human it's
uh at least to me again perhaps a dumb
intuition but it feels like there might
have been more layers sort of different
kinds of humans stacked as well of each
other um so what's true and not true
about what you said is several of the
layers of software like so the if you
hear two layers would be suppose we just
talk about two layers that would be the
operating system like you get from from
Microsoft or from Apple like iOS or the
Windows operating system and let's say
applications that run on top of it like
Word or Excel so both the operating
system could be written in C and the
application could be written in C so but
you could construct those two layers and
the applications absolutely do call upon
the operating system and the change was
that both of them could be written in
higher-level languages so it's one step
of a translation but you can still build
many layers of abstraction of software
on top of that and that's how things are
done today so still today many of the
layers that you'll you'll deep deal with
you may deal with debuggers you may deal
with linkers there's libraries many of
those today will be written in C++ say
even though that language is pretty
ancient and even the Python interpreter
is probably written in C or C++ so lots
of layers there are probably written in
these some old fashioned efficient
languages that still take one step to
produce these instructions produce RISC
instructions but they're composed each
layer of software invokes one another
through these interfaces and you can get
ten layers of software that way so in
general the risk was developed here
Berkeley it was kind of the three places
that were
these radicals that advocated for this
against the rest of community where IBM
Berkeley and Stanford you're one of
these radicals and how radical did you
feel how confident did you feel how a
doubtful were you that risk might be the
right approach because it made you can
also Intuit that is kind of taking a
step back into simplicity not forward
into simplicity ya know it was easy to
make yeah it was easy to make the
argument against it well this was my
colleague John Hennessy at Stanford and
I we were both assistant professors and
for me I just believed in the power of
our ideas I thought what we were saying
made sense Moore's Law is going to move
fast the other thing that I didn't
mention is one of the surprises of these
complex instruction sets you could
certainly write these complex
instructions if the programmer is
writing them in themselves it turned out
to be kind of difficult for the compiler
to generate those complex instructions
kind of ironically you'd have to find
the right circumstances that that just
exactly fit this complex instruction it
was actually easier for the compiler to
generate these simple instructions so
not only did these complex instructions
make the hard work more difficult to
build often the compiler wouldn't even
use them and so it's harder to build the
compiler doesn't use them that much the
simple instructions go better with
Moore's Law that you know the number of
transistors is doubling every every two
years so we're gonna have you know the
you want to reduce the time to design
the microprocessor that may be more
important than these number instructions
so I think we believed in the that we
were right that this was the best idea
then the question became in these
debates well yeah that's a good
technical idea but in the business world
this doesn't matter there's other things
that matter it's like arguing that if
there's a standard with the railroad
tracks and you've come up with a better
with but the whole world has covered
railroad tracks so you'll your ideas
have no chance of success
commercial success it was technically
right but commercially it'll be
insignificant yeah this it's kind of sad
that this world the history of human
civilization is full of good ideas that
lost because somebody else came along
first with a worse idea and it's good
that in the computing world at least
some of these have oh well you could are
I mean it's probably still sisk people
that say yeah and what happened was what
was interesting
Intel a bunch of the sis
companies with Sisk instruction sets of
vocabulary they gave up but not Intel
what Intel did to its credit because
Intel's vocabulary was in the in the
personal computer and so that was a very
valuable vocabulary because the way we
distribute software is in those actual
instructions it's in the instructions of
that instruction set so they that you
don't get that source code what the
programmers wrote you get after it's
been translated into the list level
that's if you were to get a floppy disk
or download software it's in the
instructions of that instruction set so
the x86 instruction set was very
valuable so what Intel did cleverly and
amazingly is they had their chips in
hardware do a translation stuff they
would take these complex instructions
and translate them into essentially in
RISC instructions in Hardware on the fly
you know at at gigahertz clock speeds
and then any good idea that risk people
had they could use and they could still
be compatible with us with this really
valuable PC software software base and
which also had very high volumes you
know a hundred million personal
computers per year so the the sisk
architecture in the business world was
actually one in in this PC era so just
going back to the the time of designing
risk when you design an instruction set
architecture do you think like a
programmer do you think like a
microprocessor engineer do you think
like a artist a philosopher do you think
and software and hardware I mean is it
art designs
yeah I'd say I think designing a goods
instruction set is an art and I think
you're trying to balance the the
simplicity and speed of execution with
how well easy it will be for compilers
to use it right you're trying to create
an instruction set that everything in
there can be used by compilers there's
not things that are missing
that'll make it difficult for the
program to run they run efficiently but
you want it to be easy to build as well
so it's that kind of so you're thinking
I'd say you're thinking hard we're
trying to find a hard spur software a
compromise that'll work well and and
it's you know it's you know it's a
matter of taste right it's it's kind of
fun to build instruction sets it's not
that hard to build an instruction set
but to build one that catches on and
people use you know you have to be you
know fortunate to be the right place at
the right time or have a design that
people really like are you using metrics
says is it quantifiable because you kind
of have done anticipate the kind of
programs that people are right yet ahead
of time so is that can you use numbers
can use metrics can you quantify
something ahead of time or is this again
that's the art part where you're kind of
know it's a big a big change kind of
what happened I think from Hennessey's
and my perspective in the 1980s what
happened was going from kind of really
you know taste and hunches to
quantifiable and in fact he and I wrote
a textbook at the end of the 1980s
called computer architecture or a
quantitative approach I heard of that
and and it's it's the thing it had a
pretty big big impact in the field
because we went from textbooks that kind
of listed so here's what this computer
does and here's the pros and cons and
here's what this computer does in pros
and cons to something where there were
formulas
in equations where you could measure
things so specifically for instruction
sets what we do in some other fields do
is we agree upon a set of programs which
we call benchmarks and a suite of
programs and then you develop both the
hardware and the compiler and you get
numbers on how well your your computer
does given its instruction set and how
well you implemented it in your
microprocessor and how good your
compilers are and in computer
architecture we you know using
professors terms we grade on a curve
rather than greater than absolute scale
so when you say you know this these
programs run this fast well that's kind
of interesting but how do you know it's
better while you compare it to other
computers at the same time so the best
way we know how to make turned it into a
kind of more science and experimental
and quantitative is to compare yourself
to other computers or the same era that
have the same access the same kind of
technology on commonly agreed benchmark
programs so maybe two toss-up two
possible directions we can go one is
what are the different trade-offs in
designing architectures we've been
already talking about Siskin risk but
maybe a little bit more detail in terms
of specific features that you were
thinking about and the other side is
what are the metrics that you're
thinking about when looking at these
trade-offs yeah well let's talk about
the metrics so during these debates we
actually had kind of a hard time
explaining convincing people the ideas
and partly we didn't have a formula to
explain it and a few years into it we
hit upon the formula that helped explain
what was going on and I think if we can
do this see how it works orally just is
this so the yes if I can do a formula
Orly LC so the so fundamentally the way
you measure performance is how long does
it take a program to run a program if
you have ten programs and typically
these benchmarks were sweet because
you'd want to have ten programs so they
could represents the lots of different
applications so for these ten programs
how long does it take to run
now when you're trying to explain why it
took so long you could factor how long
it takes a program to run into three
factors one of the first one is how many
instructions did it take to execute so
that's the that's the what we've been
talking about you know the instructions
of Academy how many did it take all
right the next question is how long did
each instruction take to run on average
so you multiply the number instructions
times how long it took to run and that's
your help time okay so that's but now
let's look at this metric of how long
did it take the instruction to run well
it turns out the way we could build
computers today is they all have a clock
and you've seen this when you if you buy
a microprocessor it'll say 3.1 gigahertz
or 2.5 gigahertz and more gigahertz is
good well what that is is the speed of
the clock so 2.5 gigahertz turns out to
be 4 billions of instruction or 4
nanoseconds so that's the clock cycle
time but there's another factor which is
what's the average number of clock
cycles that takes per instructions so
it's number of instructions average
number of clock cycles in the clock
cycle time
so in these risks as debates we would we
they would concentrate on but risk makes
needs to take more instructions and we'd
argue what may be the clock cycle is
faster but what the real big difference
was was the number of clock cycles per
instruction or instruction ssa what
about the mess up the beautiful mess of
parallelism in the whole picture
parallelism which has to do was say how
many instructions could execute in
parallel and things like that
you could think of that as affecting the
clock cycles per instruction because
it's the average clock cycles per
instruction so when you're running a
program if it if it took a hundred
billion instructions and on average it
took two clock cycles per instruction
and they were 4 nanoseconds you could
multiply that out and see how long it
took to run and there's all kinds of
tricks to try and reduce the number of
clock cycles per instruction but it
turned out that the way they would do
these complex instructions is they would
actually build what we would call an
interpreter in a simpler a very simple
hardware interpreter but it turned out
that for
sis constructions if you had to use one
of those interpreters it would be like
10 clock cycles per instruction where
the risk instructions could be too so
there'd be this factor of five advantage
in clock cycles per instruction we have
to execute say 25 or 50 percent more
instructions so that's where the wind
would come and then you can make an
argument whether the clock cycle times
are the same or not but pointing out
that we could divide the benchmark
results time per program into three
factors and the biggest difference in
risk consists was the clock cycles per
you execute a few more instructions but
the clock cycles per instruction is much
less and that was what this debate once
we made that argument then people say
okay I get it and so we went from it was
outrageously controversial in you know
1982 that maybe probably by 1984 so
people said oh yeah technically they've
got a good argument
you